Hey everybody, it's Sean Hayes, I'm here with Jason Bateman and Will Arnett and this is a show called Smart List where one of us brings on a surprise guest that the other two don't know about and it's super fun and here we go. Is that good? No, that was terrible. Smart List. Smart List. Smart List.
大家好，我是肖恩·海斯（Sean Hayes），我和杰森·贝特曼（Jason Bateman）以及威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）在这里，这个节目叫Smart List。我们中的一个人会带一位神秘嘉宾来，另外两个人事先都不知道，这超级有趣，我们开始吧。这样好吗？不，这太糟糕了。Smart List。Smart List。Smart List。
Just chat like you're a normal human being, Sean, can you do that for like a minute? Is that possible? Well, I've got it. Do you have a stop on? You can go. I have this pair of shorts that I wear and I get embarrassed for myself because they're on the verge of being too short like the 1970s. Do you prefer short shorts or like longboard shorts?
像个正常人一样聊天，肖恩，你能坚持哪怕一分钟吗？这有可能吗？好吧，我有办法了。你身上挂着个停止标志吗？你可以走了。我有一条常穿的短裤，我自己都觉得挺尴尬的，因为它们短得快赶上20世纪70年代的风格了。你更喜欢超短裤还是那种长滑板裤？
Well, this is going to sound like I'm quoting a song, but I like short shorts. You mean for all the 80 plus listeners? I like a short short. If you're asking me honestly, I do like a short short. Well, because look what I'm asking, you're just fucking disgusting. Thank you. You would wear dentifloss just to show off your legs and your tan. That's true.
嗯，这听起来像是在引用一首歌，但我喜欢超短裤。你是说为了所有80岁以上的听众吗？我喜欢超短裤。如果你老实问我，我是真的很喜欢超短裤。好吧，因为你看我问的这是什么，你简直恶心透顶。谢谢。你甚至愿意穿着牙线内裤来炫耀你的腿和美黑。确实如此。
My Alessandra said to me today, she said, you have the smallest tan line like I wear a G-string, which I don't. You kind of do. I'd love to. Have you ever worn a G-string? You look like you would wear it confidently and people would be so embarrassed for you. I bought a Speedo when I went to France. I bought a Speedo as a bit and I wore it a little bit.
我的亚历桑德拉今天对我说，她说，你晒黑的痕迹太小了，就像我穿了G弦裤一样，虽然我并没有。你确实有点像。我很想看。你穿过G弦裤吗？你看起来就是那种会自信地穿上它，而让大家为你感到无比尴尬的人。我去法国时买过一条Speedo泳裤。我买Speedo纯属开玩笑，还穿过一会儿。
My friend was like, dude, you got to stop with the Speedo. It's disgusting. It was so gross. So Will, if you and I were on a deserted island together, how long before you made the first move? How long is the expected life expectancy? On the island? On the island.
我的朋友说，老兄，你得别穿这Speedo了。太恶心了。真的太恶心了。所以，威尔，如果你和我一起流落荒岛，你得花多长时间才会迈出第一步？预期寿命是多久？在岛上？在岛上。
I don't know. Maybe like three years. You're looking at me for three years. How long before you go, hey, that looks, I'd like to hit that. Two years and 364 days. If we knew that at three years it was over, I guess it was the last day. The last day you'd be like, I could hit that. Just her fuck it for the last day.
我不知道。大概三年吧。你看着我过了三年。你得花多长时间才会说，嘿，那看起来不错，我想上。两年零364天。如果我们知道满三年就结束了，我想那就是最后一天。最后一天你就会想，我可以上那个。反正最后一天了，豁出去吧。
Yeah, fuck it. What do I care? Okay. There's Jason. Now I've got it. And we're rolling. Yeah. Can you hear us?
对，豁出去吧。我管他呢。好吧。杰森也在。现在我明白了。我们开始录了。能听到我们说话吗？
Oh, this is so exciting. I can hear you and I can see you. You're receiving me. So Jason, you missed my incredible question earlier. If we were all three on a deserted island together, how long before both of you made a move on me? To eat you? Yes.
哦，这太让人兴奋了。我能听到你，也能看到你。你收到我的信号了。所以，杰森，你错过了我刚才那个不可思议的问题。如果我们三个一起流落荒岛，你们两个得花多长时间才会对我下手？吃了你？对。
He'd see me as a bag of Doritos. Baitment snackie tendencies, I mean hour six. I know. Okay, guys, our guest today, I think we've lost the three people that were listening to us. I've never met this person. I've always wanted to. I'm a huge fan.
他会把我当成一包多力多滋。贝特曼有吃货的倾向，我觉得也就第六个小时吧。我知道。好吧，伙计们，我们今天的嘉宾，我觉得我们已经失去了刚才那三个听众了。我从没见过这个人。我一直很想见他。我是他的超级粉丝。
This person probably hung up too. He's an author, a philosopher, a neuroscientist, and he has a very successful podcast. His academic background is in philosophy and cognitive neuroscience. So I totally geek out on this. Definitely has hung up. Mostly I wanted to meet him because of his religious philosophies. He's the first person to introduce me to the idea of atheism. So I'm super duper excited for all of us to meet Sam Harris.
这个人可能也挂断电话了。他是一位作家、哲学家、神经科学家，他还有一个非常成功的播客。他的学术背景是哲学和认知神经科学。所以我对此完全着迷。他绝对已经挂了。我主要是因为他的宗教哲学想见他。他是第一个向我介绍无神论理念的人。所以我超级无敌激动，我们大家终于能见到山姆·哈里斯（Sam Harris）了。
No kidding. Gentlemen. Hello, Sam. Sam Harris. Hello there. Nice to meet you. I'm so glad you didn't hang up on us. I didn't know we were going to be talking about the X-rated Donner party.
真的吗？各位先生。你好，山姆。山姆·哈里斯。你好啊。很高兴你没挂我们的电话。我没想到我们会讨论限制级唐纳党（Doner Party）的事。
So listen, first of all, Sam, I can't even believe I'm looking at you. I'm meeting you. If you only knew how I've been a super duper gigantic fan for so long, you are so fasting to me and there's so much to get to. I feel like, you know, it's like Christmas morning and Christmas, you know, is about the birth of our Lord and Savior, Jesus Christ, of which you don't believe. But because of you, I first started deeply questioning all things religion. And I want to just start at the beginning.
所以听着，首先，山姆，我简直不敢相信我在看着你，在见你。如果你知道我当了你多久的超级无敌巨型粉丝，你对我有巨大的吸引力，有太多的话题要聊了。我觉得这就像圣诞节的早晨，你知道的，圣诞节是关于我们的救世主耶稣基督的诞生，而你是不相信这些的。但因为你，我才开始真正深入质疑所有宗教相关的事情。我想从头开始。
Can you pinpoint the one experience or person or whatever it is that enlightened you? Because I can look to you and say you were the person that enlightened me. On this particular point of disbelief in a personal God. Yeah. All that. Yeah. It really wasn't one person. I mean, I think I, you know, most people who don't get indoctrinated into religion
你能指出是哪种经历、哪个人或者到底是什么东西启蒙了你吗？因为我看着你，就会说你就是那个启蒙了我的人。关于不相信个人神明这一点。是的。诸如此类。是的。其实并不是某一个人。我的意思是，我觉得，大多数没有被灌输宗教思想的人，
start that way. Right? I mean, you have to be convinced that a certain book was authored by the creator of the universe. Otherwise, you wouldn't just spontaneously form that belief. So I didn't, in my upbringing, I didn't have any, I didn't have any atheist indoctrination in it. I mean, I honestly knew, before I wrote my first book, The End of Faith, which sort of inducted me into the crowd of atheists, I didn't think in terms of atheism versus religion.
一开始都是这样的。对吧？我的意思是，你必须得先被灌输并相信某本书是由宇宙创造者撰写的。否则，你不会凭空就产生这种信仰。所以在我成长过程中，我没有接触过任何无神论的灌输。我的意思是，老实说，在我写第一本书《信仰的终结》（The End of Faith）之前，这本书把我带入了无神论者的群体，我当时甚至不是从无神论对立于宗教的角度来思考的。
In fact, the word atheist doesn't even appear in the book, but I did not have a religious background I was reacting to. I mean, The End of Faith, as you know, was my immediate reaction to September 11th. I mean, once people started flying planes into our buildings. Wow. I mean, after 9-11, you, you wrote that that's because I, the book I read that completely enlightened me was Letter to a Christian Nation. That was your second book.
事实上，书里连“无神论者”这个词都没出现过，但我并不是带着某种宗教背景去做反应的。我的意思是，《信仰的终结》，如你所知，是我对9·11事件的直接反应。也就是人们开始把飞机撞向我们大楼的时候。哇。我是说，9·11之后，你写过，那是因为我，我读的那本完全启蒙了我的书是《致基督教国家的信》（Letter to a Christian Nation）。那是你的第二本书。
Right. So that was my second book. Yeah. And I was reading and I was just like, yeah, why aren't we, we're never taught to question things. Well, not like in the seventies and eighties, you know, when I was growing up, we weren't told to question things or just accept it because that's the thing you were born into. You know,
对，那是我的第二本书。是的。我在读的时候就想，对啊，为什么我们，我们从来没被教导过去质疑事物。好吧，不像在七十年代和八十年代，你知道的，当我长大的时候，我们没有被告知要质疑事物，而是被要求直接接受，因为那是你生来就处于其中的事物。你知道，
Wait, wait, quick, quick. Sean, be honest. Did you read it or listen to it? It was read to me. Yeah. That's what I thought. I needed pictures, I needed pictures drawn. No.
等等，等等，快说，快说。肖恩，说实话。你是读的还是听的？是别人读给我听的。对。我就知道。我需要图画，我需要画出来的图画。不。
Um, but to you, it just seems like we're all forced to label ourselves in some kind of category of religion or lack thereof and then get judged for whatever we choose. Do you feel people have that, that, that they have to stake a claim of some kind of faith or like a non-faith or just, can someone just be neutral or it feels like we always, all of us have to say what we are. Yeah. So I've resisted that, that demand, because that really is demand that's coming from theology, right?
嗯，但对你来说，似乎我们所有人都被迫把自己贴上某种宗教或缺乏宗教信仰的标签，然后无论我们作何选择都要受到评判。你觉得人们有这种感觉吗，他们必须对某种信仰或非信仰表态，还是说，一个人可以保持中立，或者感觉我们所有人总是不得不说出自己是什么？是的。所以我也一直在抗拒这种需求，因为这确实是来自神学界的要求，对吧？
So I mean, this is a controversial point among atheists, but I've, I've often said, I mean, I think there was a talk on YouTube, I think it's called the problem with atheism. I've often said that we don't have to define ourselves in, in, in these terms. I mean, no one defines himself as a non-astrologer, right? You don't, you don't have to resist astrology by first joining a group of non-astrologers and then going to bad conferences and bad hotels, you know, and, and, and organizing around this variable of, of not being an astrologer. And that's what atheists tend to do.
所以，我的意思是，这是无神论者中一个有争议的点，但我经常说，我的意思是，YouTube上好像有个演讲，好像叫《无神论的问题》。我经常说，我们其实没必要用这些词来定义自己。我的意思是，没有人会把自己定义为“非占星术士”，对吧？你不需要通过先加入一个“非占星术士”组织，然后去糟糕的酒店参加糟糕的会议，然后围绕“不是占星术士”这个变量来组织起来，以此来抵制占星术。但无神论者往往就是这么做的。
Let me ask you this Sam, because I've always wondered this and I, I gotta say, you know, I grew up, I went to, in Canada, what was called Anglican schools, which is Episcopalian in this country. That's hockey in the morning and Bible study after that. That's right. Yeah. And then hockey. And then hockey again.
山姆，我来问你这个，因为我一直很好奇，我得说，你知道的，我在加拿大长大，我上过所谓的英国圣公会学校，也就是这里的圣公会学校。那就是早上打冰球，之后上圣经学习课。没错。对。然后是冰球。接着又是冰球。
Yeah. And then they just call it Anglicanism, but, but at Church of England, whatever, in my, but I don't know enough about it, even though I sort of studied it, et cetera, at school. And one of my sisters actually has a number of degrees of Bachelor of Religion, Master of Theology from Yale Divinity School, et cetera. But it seems to me as sort of the layman, literally, that the thing that has always lended legitimacy to religion is just time. Right?
对。然后他们只是称之为圣公宗，但，英国国教会，随便吧，但在我的，虽然我在学校里多少学过一点，但我对它了解得还不够。而且我的一个姐姐其实拥有耶鲁神学院等机构的宗教学学士学位、神学硕士学位等多个学位。但在我这个外行人看来，字面意义上的外行人，一直以来赋予宗教合法性的东西，仅仅是时间。对吧？
So, does that seem fairly accurate that after? I think more to the point death, without death, without the ending of personal time, there'd be no rationale for this. But I mean, you know, you look at the sort of the genesis, if you will, thank you, of the Mormon church, you know, Joseph Smith was laughed out of upstate New York. He was kicked out of every place that he went and, you know, that the Church of Latter Day Saints, and I mean no offense to people who happened to be, but that that was for a long time, that they were seen as heretics, whatever, and they were kicked out of every
所以，这听起来算相当准确吗？我觉得更确切地说是死亡，如果没有死亡，没有个人时间的终结，这一切就没有任何合理性了。但我的意思是，你知道，你看一下摩门教的起源（如果可以这么说的话——谢谢），约瑟夫·史密斯（Joseph Smith）当年在纽约州北部被嘲笑得待不下去。他去过的每个地方都被赶了出来，你知道的，耶稣基督后期圣徒教会（我不对碰巧信仰它的人抱有任何冒犯之意），但在很长一段时间里，他们被视为异端，无论走到哪个
town they went to. And, but eventually, over a certain amount of time, they became legitimized as a religion. Is that fair to say, and that all religions kind of go along that same route? We have a lot of religions that have come up that have been very popular in California in the last 50 years, that a generation from now will be, I don't know, I can't think of one off the top of my head, but that might be a generation from now considered to be less of a cult and more of an actual religion. That seems to be a theme.
城镇都被赶出去。但最终，经过了一段时间，他们作为一种宗教获得了合法性。这么说公平吗？所有的宗教似乎都走着同样的路线？过去50年里，我们在加州涌现出了很多非常受欢迎的宗教，再过一代人，它们就会变成，我不知道，我一时想不出具体的例子，但再过一代人，它们可能会被认为更少地被视为邪教，而更多地被视为真正的宗教。这似乎是个规律。
Well, I mean, it's not a fact that speaks to the truth of any one doctrine, obviously, right? It's just a fact that given enough time and a large enough population of subscribers, a cult begins to seem, and it begins to be treated as a mainstream religion, and then certain religions, like Mormonism is sort of on the boundary here, because the truth is we know too much about Joseph Smith. The origins of Mormonism are not sufficiently shrouded in the mists of history, so as for it to get the treatment that Christianity and Judaism and Islam get, which is a free
嗯，我的意思是，这并不是一个能证明任何单一教义真理的事实，显而易见，对吧？这只是一个事实：给予足够的时间和足够庞大的信徒群体，一个邪教就会开始显得像、并开始被当作主流宗教来对待。然后某些宗教，比如摩门教在这里有点处于边界上，因为事实是，我们对约瑟夫·史密斯了解得太多了。摩门教的起源并没有被历史的迷雾足够好地笼罩，因此无法获得基督教、犹太教和伊斯兰教所能得到的待遇——也就是对所有这些问题和奇迹享有免检权。我们只是知道，
pass on all these questions and miracles, and we just know, you know, the South Park episode on Mormonism is just too much like the actual history of Mormonism for Mormonism to survive, you know, full contact with modern reality. Oh, and the musical by those guys called Book of Mormon, it was like, awesome. But you know, my beef is simple with Catholicism. It's where's the beef, right? Yeah, where is your beef? I've been asking that.
你知道的，《南方公园》（South Park）里关于摩门教的那集，简直太像摩门教的真实历史了，以至于摩门教无法在与现代现实的全面接触中存活下来。哦，还有那群家伙写的音乐剧《摩门经》（Book of Mormon），真是太棒了。但你知道，我对天主教的意见很简单。牛肉在哪里，对吧？对，你的牛肉在哪里？我一直都在问这个。
And if we back to see, he likes to take it back to the deserted island. I'll show you where the beef is. But if you just let the dogs out and let us know what your beef is, who let the dogs in and found the beef? So look, Sam's checking his email. So my beef is simple. I grew up in a diehard Catholic family, my aunt and uncle on my mom's side were a nun and a priest, respectively, left the convent and got married.
如果我们回头看看，他喜欢把话题扯回荒岛上。我会让你看看牛肉在哪里。但如果你只是把狗放出来，让我们知道你的牛肉是什么，是谁把狗放进来并找到了牛肉呢？所以你看，山姆正在查邮件。所以我的意见很简单。我在一个坚定的天主教家庭长大，我妈妈那边的叔叔阿姨分别是一个修女和一个神父，他们后来离开修女院结了婚。
And but grew up hardcore Catholic. And then obviously the main topic of discussion, whenever you bring up Catholicism and people who question it is the hypocrisy, right? So here I am this gay kid growing up Catholic. I don't understand why I'm going to hell and, and the priests who committed child abuse to the thousands of children around the world aren't going to hell, you know, they're forgiven. And basically the hypocrisy was the thing that always bothered me. So when I saw Religialist by Bill Maher, which I thought is a great documentary, it's fascinating.
但是我是作为核心天主教徒长大的。然后很明显，每当谈到天主教以及质疑它的人时，最主要的话题就是虚伪，对吧？所以作为一个天主教徒长大的同性恋小孩，我不明白为什么我要下地狱，而那些对全世界成千上万儿童实施虐待的神父却不用下地狱，你知道的，他们被原谅了。基本上，这种虚伪一直是最让我困扰的事情。所以当我看到比尔·马尔（Bill Maher）的《宗教的荒谬》（Religulous）时，我认为这是一部很棒的纪录片，非常迷人。
He questions all religions. I emailed Bill afterwards and I go, all things being equal, if every religion in the world believes their God is the correct God, don't they all cancel each other out? Yeah. You know, that's one great point made by Bertrand Russell, a famous atheist. He said that even if we knew that one of our religions was perfectly true, given that there are so many on offer, every religious believer should expect damnation purely as a matter of probability.
他质疑了所有的宗教。我看完后给比尔发了封邮件，我说，在所有条件相同的情况下，如果世界上每个宗教都认为他们的神才是正确的神，难道他们不都互相抵消了吗？是的。你知道，著名无神论者伯特兰·罗素（Bertrand Russell）曾提出过一个非常棒的观点。他说，即使我们知道我们的某个宗教是绝对正确的，考虑到有那么多宗教可供选择，每个宗教信徒纯粹从概率上讲都应该预料到自己会下地狱。
Right? Because you got, you got at least five and the truth is you got 500. But let's just say you only have five, then at best you've got a 20% chance of having picked right or been born into the right circumstance. Right? Yeah. So, and that's just, that's, that's where we are. And so, they're mutually nullifying and I think the most important point is that all
对吧？因为你有，你至少有五个，而事实是你其实有500个。但我们就算你只有五个，那往好了说，你选对或者生在对的环境里的概率也只有20%。对吧？是的。所以，这就是现状。它们是互相抵消的，我认为最重要的一点是，所有
they are, all these religions are, are records of human conversations, right? All we have is human conversation by which to orient in reality. And the question is, do you want a 21st century conversation about the nature of reality and how to live within it? Or do you want to be anchored to an Iron Age conversation, right? Right. And religion is the only area in human thought where you win points for proving that you are immune to all possible evidence and argument.
这些宗教，所有这些宗教其实都只是人类对话的记录，对吧？我们拥有的用来在现实中定位的唯有人类的对话。问题是，你想要一场关于现实本质以及如何在其中生活的21世纪的对话呢？还是想被锚定在铁器时代的对话里？对吧？对。而在人类思想中，宗教是唯一一个只要你能证明自己对所有可能的证据和争论都免疫，就能得分的领域。
And therefore it's almost impossible to have a discussion about it. That you're not open to conversation. You're saying, what's explicit here when you're making a faith claim is that, listen, these beliefs are so important to me that I'm not willing to talk about them rationally, really. Right. I'll pretend to be rational, but the truth is I'm not actually open to evidence and argument that undercuts these cherished ideas. And what we need is a willingness to talk about the full range of human experience and
因此，几乎不可能围绕它展开讨论。你对对话是不开放的。你是说，当你提出信仰主张时，这里显而易见的是：听吧，这些信念对我是如此重要，以至于我根本不愿意理性地去讨论它们。对吧？我会假装自己很理性，但事实是，我实际上并不对那些削弱这些珍贵观念的证据和争论开放。而我们需要的是一种意愿去谈论整个人类经验，
what we want to get out of human life and what's rational to want in human life in 21st century terms. And 21st century terms are intrinsically non-divisive because this is an open conversation that does not respect accidents of the geography of one's birth or the linguistic partitioning of the world, right? The fact that you grew up speaking one language as opposed to another. No, all of the world's thinking can be translated now. We have no right to be provincial in our thinking ultimately, right?
以及我们想从人类生活中得到什么，在21世纪的语境下，想要什么才是理性的。而21世纪的语境本质上是非分裂的，因为这是一场开放的对话，它不尊重一个人出生地的地理偶然性，也不尊重世界的语言划分，对吧？你长大后说某种语言而不是另一种语言这一事实。不，现在全世界的思想都可以被翻译了。归根结底，我们在思考时没有权利表现得目光短浅，对吧？
And religion is the only system of thought where the norm, the respected norm is, no, no, the conversation has to reliably break down on these most important questions about how to live and how to raise your children and what's worth dying for. And this is, and this is all totally respectable to just prove completely immune to persuasion on these points no matter what science says, no matter what evidence shows up in terrestrial reality, right? So it's just, it's like there's no way to disconfirm these beliefs once you make this initial claim that we can't possibly understand God's will and this specific book was written
而宗教是唯一的思想体系，在这里，常规、受尊重的常规反而是：不，不，在如何生活、如何抚养孩子以及什么值得为之牺牲这些最重要的问题上，对话必须可靠地破裂。而且，无论科学怎么说，无论地面现实中出现什么证据，只要证明自己对说服完全免疫，这全都是完全受尊敬的，对吧？所以，一旦你提出了最初的主张——即我们不可能理解上帝的意志，这本特定的书是他写的——那就根本没有办法反驳这些信仰了。
by him. I think I was on a press junket once for an animated film that had to do with the subject of inventions and the interviewer asked me, you know, what's your favorite invention? And I said religion and the studio didn't like that answer. So I said, because to me, every single thing in the world is invented, right? And so every concept is invented, the word table is invented, a table itself is invented, religion is invented. Sean, are you currently on acid because this, this seems to be revelations, you are.
我想我曾经为一部关于发明主题的动画电影做过一次新闻发布会，采访者问我，“你最喜欢什么发明？”我说“宗教”，制片厂不喜欢这个答案。所以我说，因为对我来说，世上每一样东西都是被发明的，对吧？所以每个概念都是被发明的，“桌子”这个词是被发明的，桌子本身也是被发明的，宗教也是被发明的。肖恩，你现在是不是嗑了酸？因为这听起来像是神启，你绝对嗑了。
I don't want to lie down and elevate your feet. I'm, you're telling me I'm not lying down right now. So there really is no harm in anybody having these deep seated feelings of faith and belief, unless those beliefs are absolute such that if someone is on your land that you think in your religion is entitled to you, you now have the justification and the moral right to kill that person. That's where everything went off the rails because obviously none of us here probably no one listening begrudges anybody for their own little set of beliefs if that keeps them
我不想躺下来抬高你的双脚。你，你在告诉我我现在没躺下吗？所以，任何人拥有这些根深蒂固的信仰和宗教情感其实并没有什么害处，除非这些信仰是绝对的，比如如果有人在你的土地上，而你的宗教认为这土地属于你，你现在就拥有了杀死那个人的正当理由和道德权力。这就是一切脱轨的地方，因为很明显，我们这里的任何人——可能也没有任何听众——会去嫉妒或责怪别人拥有自己的那一小套信仰，只要这能让他们保持在某种道德道路上，等等。
on some moral path and et cetera. But when you start inflicting real world consequences on somebody because what somebody else believes is in violation or inconsistent with what you believe, obviously that's, that's a recipe for disaster. And that's a problem we have in so many corners of this world, right? Well, no, it actually gets worse than that because it believes don't have to be absolute. They can just be probabilistic, right? It just, just take, let's say I think that prayer often works or stands a good chance
但当你开始对某人施加现实世界的后果，仅仅因为别人的信仰违反了或不符合你的信仰，很显然，那是灾难的秘诀。这是我们在世界的许多角落都面临的问题，对吧？不，实际上情况比那更糟，因为信仰甚至不需要是绝对的。它们只需是概率性的，对吧？就拿，比方说我认为祈祷通常管用，或者很有可能管用，然后把我放在任何一种有责任的角色上，对吧？我是一名飞机驾驶员，对吧？我觉得我可以通过祈祷把飞机降落，对吧？
of working and just put me in a role of any kind of responsibility, right? I'm an airline pilot, right? And I think that I can sort of land the plane with prayer, right? I don't have to do the full safety check because God's watching out for me and my people. And I'm going to protect all these passengers just fine with a little tour of the rosary or just a couple of mantras or people believe that sort of thing right now as evidenced by the fact that they're willing to die under certain circumstances to make the rhetorical point or just imagine I'm a parent and there's endless numbers of stories of parents doing
我不需要做全面的安全检查，因为上帝在守护着我和我的人民。只要念几遍玫瑰经或者做几段真言，我就能很好地保护所有乘客。人们现在确实相信这种事情，证据就是他们愿意在某些情况下为了表达修辞观点而去死；或者想象我是一个父母，有无数的故事讲述父母对他们的孩子做着完全不理智的事情，拒绝医疗护理，或者对他们施加疯狂的惩罚，或者基于某种对宗教观念的奴隶般的依附，把他们置于客观上危险且毫无意义的环境中，对吧？
completely irrational things with their kids, denying the medical care or imposing crazy punishments on them or putting them in circumstances that are just objectively dangerous and pointless based on some kind of slavish attachment to a religious idea, right? And the truth is, there's the worst case. The most benign looking belief if held for the wrong reasons, if held dogmatically could actually lead to massive loss of life because it resists being changed through further consideration to bad evidence. And the best example of this is something like all human life is sacred, right?
事实是，这才是最糟糕的情况。看起来最良性的信仰，如果出于错误的理由去坚信，如果教条式地去坚信，实际上可能会导致巨大的生命损失，因为它拒绝通过进一步考虑糟糕的证据来进行改变。而这最好的例子就是诸如“所有人类生命都是神圣的”之类的观念，对吧？而且它是从受孕那一刻起就是神圣的，对吧？现在，这里能出什么岔子呢？那是最具体的，你知道的，非，听起来就像是一台消灭暴力的机器，对吧？
And it's sacred from the moment of conception, right? Now what could go wrong there? That is the most specific, you know, non, that sounds like just a machine to produce non-violence, right? Like I honor all human life equally all the way down to the embryo and it's all just, it's worth perfectly protecting insofar as we're able, right? Okay, great, you know, default position except we develop something like embryonic stem cell research, right?
就像我平等地尊重所有人类生命，一直到胚胎，只要我们能做到，它就完全值得受到保护，对吧？好吧，太棒了，你知道的，默认立场，除了我们开发出了类似胚胎干细胞研究的技术，对吧？
And now you've got religious maniacs who think that there are 500 souls in a Petri dish that they can't see, but they're fertilized over and you can't experiment on fertilized over. Even if you were going to develop therapies to heal people who've got full body burns or spinal cord injuries or Alzheimer's disease or so we had in the U.S. in some ways we found a workaround, but for at least a decade. Ovaltine. That was it, right? It was ovaltine.
现在，你有了那些宗教狂热分子，他们认为在看不见的培养皿里有500个灵魂，但它们是受精卵，你不能对受精卵进行实验。即使你打算开发疗法来治疗全身烧伤、脊髓损伤或阿尔茨海默病的患者——所以我们在美国在某种程度上找到了变通办法，但至少持续了十年。阿华田（Ovaltine）。就是那个，对吧？那就是阿华田。
Yeah, that was the workaround. We lost at least a decade on embryonic stem cell research simply because of religious ideas about souls in Petri dishes, right? Now, born of this default, again, on its face, totally benign notion that all human life down to the zygote needs to be respected equally, but this is quite crazy idea because you have people who are literally saying that speck in a Petri dish that I can't see is just as important to me as just as appropriate object of my moral concern as a girl who you can wheel up in a wheelchair who can't walk but may yet be able to walk if we made a breakthrough
对，那就是变通办法。我们在胚胎干细胞研究上至少倒退了十年，仅仅是因为关于培养皿里灵魂的宗教观念，对吧？现在，这种默认观念催生出了这样一个极其疯狂的观点（表面上看，它完全是良性的，认为下至合子的人类生命都应该受到平等尊重）：有些人竟然在字面意义上说，那个我看不见的培养皿里的微粒，对我和一个坐在轮椅上、走不动路但如果我们在脊髓再生上取得突破可能还能走路的女孩一样重要，同样配得上我的道德关怀。
in spinal cord regeneration. Right. I can't imagine how many arguments you've had with people with respect to that position on embryos, et cetera, and then also these are the people who are protecting those souls who are also very willing to allow everybody to have a gun or to shoot that gun or to kill criminals who are convicted of certain crimes. How can you apply the same, right? How many millions of arguments have you had on that particular subject?
对吧？我无法想象你和持这种胚胎等立场的人有过多少争论，而且这些人一方面在保护那些灵魂，另一方面又非常愿意让每个人都拥有枪支、开枪或者杀死被判特定罪行的罪犯。你怎么能把相同的……？你在这个特定主题上经历过多少百万次的争论？
Yeah, the gun topic is also interesting. I have sort of non-standard views there as well, but you can push this view into obvious hypocrisy because people are, this is, I forget what the line is, but the Christian right really cares about you up until the moment you're born, and then they have all kinds of ideas that seem to be antithetical to human well-being after that. What we need is an error-correcting mechanism by which to continually revise our policies and our norms in response to what we find out about the world. What would that be?
是的，枪支这个话题也很有趣。我在那上面也有一些非标准的观点，但你可以把这种观点推向显而易见的虚伪，因为人们——我忘了原话是怎么说的了，但基督教右翼真的很关心你，直到你出生的那一刻为止，之后他们就会持有各种与人类福祉相悖的想法。我们需要一种纠错机制，以便根据我们对世界的了解不断修正我们的政策和规范。那会是什么呢？
That really is free speech guided by intellectual honesty and guided by just an openness to evidence and argument. It's very easy to imagine the conditions under which I could be convinced that Jesus is the Son of God. There is some evidence that Jesus could show up. If the second coming and the rapture happens as advertised by evangelicals, that'll be a science experiment finally consummated in human history, right? Just take a look at Will, I mean, it's pretty damn close.
那其实就是受知识诚实引导、受对证据和争论的开放态度引导的言论自由。很容易想象在什么条件下我会被说服相信耶稣是上帝的儿子。耶稣是有可能展现出一些证据的。如果福音派宣称的第二次降临和被提（Rapture）如期发生，那将是一场终于在人类历史中完成的科学实验，对吧？看看威尔就知道了，我的意思是，这已经非常接近了。
I think that the only solution to these problems is always economic. If we make it economically disadvantageous to believe in a religion, then it'll shift. It's the only thing that moves anything in this country consistently, I mean, they ask people to stop smoking cigarettes not because the fucking government gives a shit about us smoking cigarettes, but because they didn't want to have to pay for the health care of people who are sick, full stop. I don't think, well, I mean, there's some economic policy to change here, which I don't think religions should have the tax advantages they do.
我认为解决这些问题的唯一办法永远是经济上的。如果我们让信仰宗教在经济上处于劣势，那么它就会发生转变。这是这个国家唯一能始终如一地推动任何事情改变的东西，我的意思是，他们要求人们戒烟，不是因为他妈的政府有多在乎我们抽烟，而是因为他们不想为生病的人支付医疗费用，句号。我不认为，好吧，我的意思是，这里有一些经济政策需要改变，我不认为宗教应该享有他们目前拥有的税收优惠。
I mean, that doesn't make a lot of sense, but no, you can't be punishing people economically as a method for changing their minds. I think this larger question of incentives in society is a huge one, and we definitely want to be, we want to make things easier and easier, which is to say, we want to incentive up, we want the incentives aligned for people to be moral and responsible and do the right thing, even when their moral intuitions would reliably fail. And we want them to be rational, but it's more a matter of norms, it's not a matter of actual penalties, it's like, what is it taboo to say?
我的意思是，这说不通，但是，不，你不能把在经济上惩罚人们作为改变他们想法的方法。我认为社会中关于激励机制的这个宏观问题是个巨大问题，我们绝对希望让事情变得越来越简单，也就是说，我们想要向上激励，我们要让激励机制保持一致，好让人们变得有道德、负责任并做正确的事，即使他们的道德直觉经常会失效。我们希望他们保持理性，但这更多是规范的问题，而不是实际惩罚的问题，就像是，有什么是说出来就会成为禁忌的？
You can go through a PhD program in any fundamental science, physics, chemistry, biology, to say nothing of the social sciences, and never have your religious beliefs challenged. Literally, you can get a PhD in physics, all the while being a fundamentalist Christian who thinks the universe is 6,000 years old, the Bible is a perfect record of its origin, and now you have to navigate that personally with some considerable cognitive dissonance, right? There's just no way to square your religious beliefs with what we know about physics, take the age of the universe as just a single data point, but there's no one in a lab who's
你可以在任何基础科学领域——物理学、化学、生物学，更不用说社会科学了——完成博士学位，而你的宗教信仰却从未受到挑战。字面意义上，你完全可以拿到物理学博士学位，同时却是一个原教旨主义基督徒，认为宇宙只有6000岁，圣经是其起源的完美记录，而你现在必须带着相当大的认知失调在个人层面上处理这些，对吧？你的宗教信仰根本无法与我们对物理学的了解相调和，拿宇宙的年龄作为一个单一的数据点来说，实验室里根本没有人会
going to sit you down and say, listen, I know what you think you know about God and angels and the afterlife and Jesus flying and healing the dead and raising the dead and all the rest and the coming resurrection, none of this makes any sense in terms of what you're learning here. Wait, he could fly? Yeah, he could fly. I didn't know that. Geez.
把你拉坐下来，对吧，听着，我知道你自以为对上帝、天使、来世、耶稣飞行、治愈死者、让死者复活以及接下来的复活节有什么了解，所有这些在你在这里学到的东西面前都完全说不通。等等，他会飞？对，他会飞。我不知道这个。天哪。
You too will fly if you're a rapture. That might turn me... That's why he wears a cape. That's why he wears the fucking cape. I always thought it was a different guy. You know, I remember one time being in a meeting of Alcoholics Anonymous and having a guy who was a newcomer saying, and I'm not who knows who it could be anybody, saying, he said, I can't get around this acceptance of God.
如果你经历被提，你也会飞。那可能会让我……这就是他为什么要披着斗篷的原因。这就是他为什么要他妈的披着斗篷。我一直以为那是另一个人呢。你知道，我记得有一次在匿名戒酒互助会（AA）的会议上，有一个刚来的新人说——我不知道是谁，可能任何人都是这样——他说：“我无法接受上帝这个概念。
I can't. I'm a scientist and I'm having a really tough time with it and he basically ended up dropping out. And I get... But isn't there a secular hack for that in AA? There is. We can just talk about the universe at large and all that we don't know about it. There is and I, you know, I in fact even talked to him about it and said, listen, I struggle
我做不到。我是一名科学家，我对这个真的很头疼。”他基本上最后选择退出了。我明白……但AA里面难道没有针对这个的世俗替代方案吗？有的。我们可以只谈论广袤的宇宙以及我们对它所一无所知的一切。有的，而且我，你知道的，我甚至还跟他谈过这个，并说，听着，我对有组织宗教、上帝以及所有这类东西的概念当然也觉得很纠结，但我有一个自己使用的替代方法，它能帮到我，你知道的，
with this idea of course of organized religion and God and all that sort of stuff and I have a hack that I use that helps me, you know, and that is my sort of interpretation of what God is. I use that in order to get over the same hurdle that you're talking about. Yeah. I have a totally random, but not random, but kind of random question. What do you say about all those people that claim they died on the operating table and came back?
那就是我对比上帝是什么的某种解读。我用这个来克服你正在谈论的那个同样的障碍。是的。我有一个完全随机，但又不算完全随机、有点随机的问题。你怎么看那些声称自己在手术台上死过一次又活过来的人？
Yeah. They describe what they saw above them in the room and there's so many of those stories. So what is that white light? Do you believe in it? What is it? Right. So, yeah, this is a clearly an experience people seem to have had, right? And I think the crucial thing to observe there is that none of these people actually died,
是的。他们描述了他们在房间里看到的头顶上方的情景，而且有那么多这样的故事。那么，那道白光是什么？你相信它吗？那是什么？所以，是的，这显然是一种人们似乎都有过的体验，对吧？我认为需要观察的关键一点是，这些人其实并没有真正死去，
right? Because they came back and told us about this experience, right? So they didn't suffer brain death, right? So the brain is on and functioning and the fact that they can come back and talk to us is proof of that much, right? So yeah, many of them suffered cardiac arrest or some other experience that physiologically that justifies them calling this a near death experience. And then there's all these other experiences people have in meditation and through psychedelics
对吧？因为他们回来了，并把这段经历告诉了我们，对吧？所以他们并没有经历脑死亡，对吧？所以大脑还在运转，而且他们能够回来和我们说话就是这点的证明，对吧？所以，是的，他们中的许多人经历了心脏骤停或某种其他经历，从生理学上讲，这证明了他们将此称为濒死体验。然后还有人们在冥想中、通过迷幻剂，
and just through other perturbations of their nervous system. It's DMT. It's just DMT. Yeah. Which I haven't taken. I haven't, you know, yet experimented with psychedelics, but I have not tried DMT though I would like to. Will will hook you up.
以及仅仅通过神经系统的其他扰动所获得的种种其他体验。那是DMT（二甲基色胺）。那只是DMT。对。我还没吸过。我还没，你知道，还没尝试过迷幻剂，但我没试过DMT，不过我很想试试。威尔会帮你搞定的。
Will usually the first one's free, right? There's no hookup. It's like the four of us are going on a ranch for a weekend and it's like in very safe from what I understand. I've never done it either. Oh, is this that drink you drink and then you get crazy? Well, you're talking about ayahuasca there, which is also DMT, but it's slower release orally active.
威尔，通常第一次都是免费的，对吧？没有拉皮条这回事。就像我们四个人周末去一个牧场，从我了解的情况来看非常安全。我也从来没做过。哦，就是那种你喝了然后会变疯狂的饮料吗？哦，你指的是死藤水（Ayahuasca），那里面也含有DMT，但它是口服活性、释放较慢的。
He's a rapper, isn't he? DMT? He was. Yeah. But DMT, as Samuel is about to explain to you, is the, it occurs naturally in the human body and you can also get it from plants, et cetera, right, Sam? Yeah. So DMT is a molecule which is almost ubiquitous in nature.
他是个说唱歌手吧？DMT？他以前是。是的。但DMT，正如山姆接下来要向你解释的，是，它天然存在于人体中，你也可以从植物等地方获取它，对吧，山姆？是的。所以DMT是一种在自然界中几乎无处不在的分子。
It's in plants and it's an endogenous neurotransmitter, the function of which we don't really understand, but our brains do produce it, although arguably probably not in the kind of quantity that would necessarily explain near-death experiences, but that is one thesis about near-death experience. Maybe this is a sudden release of DMT. If you're about to tell me that DMT is going to one day give us the ability to fly, I'm totally doing it. Well, apparently DMT is the smoking or injected version of it, which is a very similar experience, apparently, is the most intense psychedelic experience of, you know, among those who've
它存在于植物中，也是一种内源性神经递质，其功能我们其实并不真正理解，但我们的大脑确实会产生它，尽管可以说，其数量可能不一定能完全解释濒死体验，但这确实是关于濒死体验的一种假说。也许这是DMT的突然释放。如果你要告诉我DMT有一天能让我们获得飞行的能力，我绝对要去做。好吧，显然DMT是吸烟或注射版本的，据称这是一种非常相似的体验，是体验过所有东西的人口中最强烈的迷幻体验，他们声称，如果你摄入足够的量——而且我觉得要抽够这个量本身就是个挑战，抽起来据说非常不愉快。如果你摄入足够多，这种体验就是整个人仿佛被发射出体外去往别处，而你如何定性那个别处，（你知道的，）还有待一些争论，但那确实是一个经常让你接触到似乎是其他生命的地方，对吧？所以这些生命有一种类似外星昆虫的特质。
tried everything, they claim that if you get enough on board, and I think there's a challenge to actually smoke enough, it's supposed to be very unpleasant to smoke. So if you get enough, the experience is a being kind of shot out of your body and going elsewhere and how you characterize that elsewhere is, you know, open to some debate, but it is an elsewhere that puts you rather often in contact with what seemed to be other beings, right? So these beings have a kind of alien insect-like quality. Terrence McKenna, who raved about this for decades, called them self-transforming machine
多年来对此狂热赞赏的苔伦斯·麦肯纳（Terren McKenna）称它们为“自我变形的机械精灵”，对吧？所以你可能会突然出现在一个房间里，这些精灵似的外星人在创造各种物体（按照苔伦斯的说法，那是一种语言），这就像是，你知道的，最耀眼夺目、镶满珠宝的、法贝热彩蛋（Fabergé egg）般充满意义的物件，它们正忙着交给你，并让你去做它们在做的事情，对吧？但这里现象学的关键部分是……
elves, right? So you could suddenly appear in a room where these elf-like aliens are creating objects which, you know, on Terrence's account were a kind of language and it's just like the most, you know, blindingly beautiful, bejeweled, fabricé eggs of meaning that they're busily trying to give you and to get you to do what they're doing, right? But the crucial part of the phenomenology here is... Jason and Will are my DMT. That's how I got into it.
杰森和威尔就是我的DMT。我就是这么入坑的。我想你马上就要说到重点了，那就是这确实会发生在人们身上，而且人们会描述出非常相似的体验，对吧？不过到那里的过程听起来像地狱一样难受。好吧，有趣的地方在于，与大多数其他迷幻体验不同——在那些体验中，仅仅是感觉你对现实的感知彻底改变了，对吧？你可能会在这一切中失去自我意识，你知道的，这在使用LSD（麦角酸二乙酰胺）或赛洛西宾（魔菇）时非常常见。
I think you're going to get to it, which is that this happens to people and people describe very similar experiences, right? It sounds like hell getting there, though. Well, the thing that's interesting about this is that unlike most other psychedelic experiences where it is just that the sense is of having your perception of reality totally changed, right? And you can lose your sense of self in all of that and, you know, that's very common, you know, with LSD or psilocybin.
但在使用DMT时，（再次强调，是指吸烟版，我不认为这在死藤水里那么常见，死藤水有它自己的一系列体验。）吸烟或注射DMT的体验是：被带到别处，发现自己与其他生命产生了联系。而且再次说明，这些生命几乎从来都不是人类宗教中衍生出来的角色，对吧？人们遇到的不是圣母玛利亚或耶稣，而是外星人、昆虫
With DMT, you know, again, the smoked version, I don't think this is quite as common on ayahuasca. It's got its own range of experiences. But the smoked or injected experience of DMT is one of being put elsewhere and finding yourself in relationship to other beings. And again, these beings are almost never the characters sprung from, you know, a human religion, right? Is that people aren't meeting the Virgin Mary or Jesus, they're meeting aliens or insects
或爬行动物。我的意思是，像，你知道的，有个家伙声称自己在其中一个案例研究中被一条鳄鱼强奸了。也许那是在那个岛上，肖恩。可能没有听起来那么好。是的。给你。但再次说明，对引起我注意的是，人们经常这样描述，同样的体验，
or reptiles. I mean, like, you know, one guy claimed to have been raped by a crocodile, you know, in one of these case studies. Maybe it's on that island, Sean. Probably not as good as it sounds. Yeah. There you go. But again, what's striking to me is that people often describe this, the same experience,
那些多年来经常描述遇到这些外星人、这些昆虫般的小人或类似东西的人，他们都有这些相似的特征和相似的体验，这太了不起了。是的。所以大家的记忆里都是同一只可爱的鳄鱼。并不是每个人都能遇到鳄鱼。那不是每个人都能遇到的。那是你不想面对的Boss战。
people who, you know, over the years will often describe meeting these aliens, these little insect-like people or whatever, and they all have these sort of similar characteristics and similar experience, which is remarkable. Yeah. So the same, same cute crocodile in everybody's recollection. Not everybody gets the crocodile. That's not everybody gets the crocodile. That's the boss fight you don't want.
而且整个体验大概只有20分钟。是的。不是8个小时。这是另一个惊人的地方。时间更短。而且没有费用。如果是熟人圈子，这还是免费的。
And the experience is like 20 minutes. Yeah. It's not eight hours. That's the other thing that's amazing. It's like, it's less. And there's no fee. This is free. If you're in the right circle.
有链接吗？有什么链接之类的吗？对买得起的人来说是免费的，对买不起的人来说非常昂贵。是的。我们在聊天里有一个折扣码，杰森，你可以……我知道你很注重正念和冥想。是的。所以，是的。
Is there a link? Is there a link or anything? Free, free to those who can afford it, very expensive to those who can't. Yes. We have a discount code in the chat, Jason, and you can... I know you're big on mindfulness and meditation. Yeah. So, yeah.
所以，冥想是接触这片领域的另一种方式，实际上，它也塑造了我对宗教的看法，因为我在20多岁时花了很多时间练习冥想。我在无声冥想静修中度过了将近两年时间，在佛教语境下，但并没有真正把自己当成佛教徒，只是想探索在改变当下对头脑和世界的体验方面到底有什么可能是存在的。然后，我写的第一本书就是我的努力，试图将这些洞见与我们通过21世纪的方法对头脑的理解结合起来。
So, meditation is another way of coming at some of this terrain, and it's actually, it informed my view of religion too, because I spent in my 20s, a lot of time, practicing meditation. I spent close to two years on silent meditation retreats, Buddhist context, but without thinking to myself really as a Buddhist, just wanting to explore just what was possible in terms of changing my moment to moment experience of the mind and the world. And then, the first books I wrote were my effort to bring those kinds of insights into harmony with what we could understand about the mind through 21st century methods like
因此，冥想是探索这一领域的方法之一，实际上，它也影响了我对宗教的看法，因为我在二十多岁时花了很多时间练习冥想。我有近两年的时间在佛教背景的寂静冥想静修中度过，但我并没有真正把自己当作佛教徒，只是想探索在改变我对头脑和世界的每时每刻的体验方面有哪些可能。然后，我写的第一本书就是我的努力，试图将这些见解与我们通过21世纪的方法（例如...）对头脑的理解协调起来。
neuroscience and moral philosophy and philosophy of mind. And so, there's clearly a baby in the bathwater we want to save in religion. I mean, there's no question that there's an experience you can have that makes you feel very much like someone like Jesus or Buddha, like unconditional love is a state of mind that can be experienced. And you can get there on MDMA if you are lucky, and you can get there by practicing meditation. And there are all kinds of other experiences on the menu, whether you get there through something like DMT or LSD or psilocybin, it's just like the mansion of possible experience
神经科学、道德哲学和心智哲学。因此，宗教中显然有一些我们想要保留的精华。我的意思是，毫无疑问，你可以体验到一种感觉，让你非常像耶稣或佛陀那样，比如无条件之爱是一种可以体验到的心智状态。如果你运气好的话，你可以通过MDMA（摇头丸）达到这种状态，也可以通过练习冥想达到。菜单上还有各种各样的其他体验，无论你是通过DMT、LSD还是赛洛西宾（迷幻蘑菇）来实现，它就像是可能体验的豪宅
is vast. And some of these experiences have a lot to say about how good life could be in the present for more and more of us if we got our shit together. And unlike psychedelics, meditation is a very incremental and fairly predictable way of navigating that landscape of changes in mental state. Right. Now, Sam, back to my two kind of just more random questions. Is there an afterlife is my one question and my second, my last question to you is define
浩瀚无垠。如果我们能振作起来，其中一些体验对于我们越来越多的人在当下如何过上美好的生活有很多启示。与致幻剂不同，冥想是一种非常循序渐进且相当可预测的方式，可以用来驾驭这种精神状态变化的风景。没错。好啦，萨姆，回到我那两个比较随性的问题上。我的第一个问题是，真的有来世吗？我的第二个，也是最后一个问题是，请定义
a good life because so many people want to achieve happiness and what does that mean to you? Right. So, so on the first question, that really is a question about what is the relationship between consciousness and the physical world, right? So if consciousness is something that is being produced by information processing in the brain, in our case, and the brain dies, then you would expect conscious that the light that is consciousness to go out, right, without residue, there's no, there's nothing to lift
何谓美好生活，因为有太多人想要获得幸福，这在你看来意味着什么？好的，关于第一个问题，这实际上是一个关于意识与物理世界之间关系的问题，对吧？因此，如果意识是由我们大脑中的信息处理所产生的东西，而在我们的情况下，当大脑死亡时，你就会期望意识——作为意识之光的灯——会熄灭，对吧，不留一丝痕迹，没有任何东西可以从
off the brain and go elsewhere, certainly not to a heaven that, you know, has rivers of milk and honey and etc. So the truth is we don't actually know how consciousness is entangled with the physics of things. You know, at what point it arises, we don't really know that neurons produce it, although you're on, you're certainly on firm ground in, in neuroscience and in science generally, if you, if that's your default assumption, there's every reason to believe that the mind, you know, the rest of mind, you know, language processing and ability to see and hear and
大脑中抽离并去往别处，当然不是去往那种有着流淌着牛奶和蜂蜜等景象的天堂。所以事实是，我们实际上并不知道意识是如何与事物的物理特性纠缠在一起的。你知道，它在什么时候产生，我们其实并不知道神经元是否产生了它，尽管如果你以这个为默认假设，你在神经科学和一般科学领域中肯定是站稳了脚跟的，有充分的理由相信心智，你知道，其余的心智，你知道，语言处理能力以及看、听、
smell and think that that is what the brain is doing, right? And if you damage parts of the brain, you can selectively damage those capacities. And if you damage the whole brain of death, there's every reason to believe you lose all of that, right? And this is another reason why the near death experiences are a little fishy because people go into a tunnel of light and they recognize their grandmother and they have conversations apparently in, in, in a language they understand with. I see a hot crocodile, I've been trying to get his number, sorry, keep going Sam.
闻和思考的能力，这正是大脑在做的事情，对吧？如果你损伤大脑的某些部分，你可以选择性地损伤这些能力。如果你因死亡而损伤了整个大脑，有充分的理由相信你会失去这一切，对吧？这也是为什么濒死体验有点可疑的另一个原因，因为人们进入了一个光之隧道，他们认出了自己的祖母，并且显然在用一种他们听得懂的语言进行对话。我看到一条辣鳄鱼，我一直在试图要他的电话号码，抱歉，萨姆，你继续。
So to recognize anyone's grandmother or a crocodile, still, you're still retaining some faculties which we have every reason to believe are being mediated by brain activity, right? So to know that it was a crocodile and not a buffalo is to know something about animals. There was no doubt. No doubt. Okay, so, sorry. So that part of your temporal lobe was probably still online. Now, so the thesis here is that if you destroy the brain entirely, as if by magic, all of
所以要认出任何人的祖母或鳄鱼，你仍然保留着一些官能，而我们有充分的理由相信这些官能是由大脑活动介导的，对吧？所以能分辨出那是鳄鱼而不是水牛，就是了解关于动物的一些知识。毫无疑问。毫无疑问。好吧，所以，抱歉。所以你颞叶的那部分可能仍然在线。现在，这里的论点是，如果你像变魔术一样完全摧毁了大脑，你的
your faculties, you know, go elsewhere and you are, you know, you enjoy some afterlife. There's reason to be skeptical of that, but consciousness itself, the fact that the lights are on, right, the fact that seeing and hearing and other sense experiences are associated with a point of view, right? Which need not be so, right? I mean, we're, we're in the process of building artificial intelligence, which can see and hear and, and detect faces and, and, and parse natural language and all the rest. And very soon on some of these tasks, it's already doing it better than we are.
所有官能，你知道，去了别的地方，然后你，你知道，享受某种来世。有理由对此持怀疑态度，但意识本身，灯还亮着的事实，对吧，看到、听到和其他感官体验与某个视角相关联的事实，对吧？而这本不必如此，对吧？我的意思是，我们，我们正在构建人工智能，它可以看、听、检测人脸、解析自然语言等等。而且很快在其中一些任务上，它已经做得比我们好了。
And ultimately we'll do everything better than we do. But there'll be an open question, is there something that is like to be one of these machines? I, are these machines conscious? Wait till the religious folks get their hands on those robots. Yeah, right. Yeah, exactly. Then we'll have to convert them.
最终它会把所有事情都做得比我们好。但这是一个悬而未决的问题：成为这些机器之一是一种什么样的体验？这些机器有意识吗？等着宗教人士对那些机器人下手吧。没错，对。没错，正好。然后我们得去感化他们。
But, but no, but then there's a real question of, you know, could we inadvertently build conscious machines or areas of the internet that inhabited by, you know, billions of conscious minds, right? Ex Machina. Did you ever see that movie, Ex Machina? Yeah, yeah. That was great. That was great.
但是，但是没有，不过这里有一个真正的问题，你知道，我们是否会无意中创造出有意识的机器，或者互联网上由数十亿个有意识的心智居住的区域，对吧？《机械姬》。你有没有看过那部电影，《机械姬》？对，对。那太棒了。那太棒了。
But either individual intelligences or simulated worlds populated by conscious minds. The interesting case is that we could do this inadvertently. It could be just a fact that as you scale up in intelligence, consciousness comes along for the ride at some point, right? And we could get there without actually understanding how consciousness arises. And we could then find ourselves in the position, wittingly or not, of having created hells and populated them, right? We could create machines that can suffer every bit as much as we can suffer or even more,
但无论是个体智能，还是由有意识的心智填充的模拟世界。有趣的情况是，我们可能会无意中做到这一点。这可能是一个事实，即随着智能的提升，意识在某个时刻也会顺理成章地出现，对吧？而我们可能会在并不真正理解意识是如何产生的情况下达到这一步。然后我们会发现自己陷入了一种有意或无意地创造了地狱并将其人口填满的境地，对吧？我们可以创造出能够承受和我们一样多的痛苦，甚至承受更多痛苦的机器，
you know, suffer in ways that we can't even imagine because these minds are not constituted like our own. And obviously, that'd be a terrible thing to do. And that's something that we could stumble into in a moral quandary if you talk about unplugging it. Yeah, exactly. I mean, are you murdering your computer? If you unplug it once your computer is conscious?
你知道，以我们甚至无法想象的方式承受痛苦，因为这些心智的构成与我们不同。显然，那将是一件可怕的事情。而如果我们谈到拔掉它的电源，那将是我们可能陷入道德困境而偶然遭遇的事情。对，没错。我的意思是，你在谋杀你的计算机吗？如果你一旦你的计算机有了意识就拔掉它的电源？
Sure. Given that, so if you think that the conscious mind, like if we were to give Sean a lobotomy, would we notice? This is a great question. I mean, because seriously, I haven't understood a word you said this entire podcast. It's a great question. I'm going to have to look at it. There are things like lobotomies where you wouldn't notice where the split brain procedure
当然。鉴于此，所以如果你认为有意识的心智，比如如果我们对肖恩进行脑白质切除术，我们会注意到吗？这是一个好问题。我的意思是，因为说实话，你在这整个播客中说的每一个字我都听不懂。这是一个好问题。我得研究一下。有些事情比如脑白质切除术，你不会注意到，而裂脑手术
is something that is, you know, grand mal epileptics get where you divide the left and right hemispheres. And for the longest time, people thought these people were unchanged. But what actually happens is that you have now created two islands of subjectivity in the brain and two independent points of view where the right hemisphere quite literally doesn't know what the left hemisphere is doing. And you can tease this out in experiments. And you have created two subjects, which is fascinating, but I didn't answer your question. I think all of this is to say that the question about an afterlife or survival of death is
是那种，你知道，重度癫痫患者会做的手术，将左右半球分离开来。在很长一段时间里，人们认为这些人没有改变。但实际发生的是，你现在在大脑中创造了两个主观性孤岛和两个独立的视角，其中右半球简直不知道左半球在做什么。你可以在实验中琢磨出这一点。你创造了两个主体，这很迷人，但我没有回答你的问题。我想所有这些都是为了说明，关于来世或死后生存的问题是一个
a question about how consciousness arises. So whatever is true there, again, we have to bracket that. We don't yet know, although you're not going to embarrass yourself in science by assuming that it is at some level produced by computations in the brain and therefore lights go out when you die. But is there going to be a moment where scientists agree on that? Is that imminent? Do you think that they're going to say, okay, we've...
关于意识是如何产生的问题。因此，无论那里真相如何，我们再次需要将其暂且搁置。我们还不知道，尽管如果在科学中你假设它在某种程度上是由大脑中的计算产生的，并因此在你死后灯光熄灭，你并不会因此感到尴尬。但是科学家们会对这一点达成一致吗？这迫在眉睫吗？你认为他们会说，好吧，我们已经……
This is what happens when you die, do you mean? Or no, or we finally figured out the moment where consciousness arises. I think it's conceivable, but I think what's even more likely is that we will lose sight of it as an interesting question because we will build machines that seem conscious to us. They will drive our intuitions that cause us to ascribe consciousness to other people so fully that we will just lose sight of it as being an interesting question. At a certain point, whether they're humanoid robots or whether it's Siri on your phone,
你是说这就是人死后发生的事？还是不，或者我们终于弄清楚了意识产生的时刻？我认为这是可以想象的，但我认为更有可能的是，我们会忽视它作为一个有趣的问题，因为我们将建造在我们看来具有意识的机器。它们会驱使我们的直觉，导致我们将意识如此完全地归因于其他人，以至于我们只是不再将它视为一个有趣的问题。在某个特定点上，无论是人形机器人还是你手机上的Siri，
knowing more about you and passing every possible test of rationality and empathy and everything else that you get from another person, so well that, again, you'll just find yourself in relationship, right? You won't lose any more thought over whether this thing is conscious than you worry that whether your dog is conscious or whether your wife is, right? Right. Insert joke there. Did you like that movie, Her?
它对你了解更多，并通过了理性、同理心以及你能从另一个人身上得到的其他一切可能测试，做得如此之好，以至于你会再次发现自己与它建立了关系，对吧？你不会再费神去思考这东西是否有意识，就像你不会担心你的狗是否有意识，或者你的妻子是否有意识一样，对吧？对。此处应有笑话。你喜欢那部电影《她》吗？
Spike Jon's this movie? Yeah. Yeah, no, I thought that was pretty interesting too. Yeah. I thought the final vision of just them losing interest in us and disappearing was a great idea. Yeah, me too. Beautiful movie.
斯派克·琼斯的这部电影？对。对，不，我也觉得那挺有趣的。对。我觉得他们最终对我们失去兴趣并消失的宏伟设想是一个极好的主意。对，我也是。美丽的电影。
Spoiler. Yeah. So back to my other question. So sorry to repeat it. But like, so what constitutes a good life for Sam Harris? Ultimately, meditation is the reference point here. And I guess I would come back to this point of confusion that is very easy for people to fall into, which ultimately, meditation can mean many different things, right?
剧透。对。所以回到我的另一个问题。很抱歉重复一遍。但是，萨姆·哈里斯的美好生活究竟包含什么？归根结底，冥想是这里的参考点。我想我会回到人们很容易陷入的那种混乱状态，归根结底，冥想可以意味着许多不同的事情，对吧？
But what I mean by it and what I think we should mean by it is it's not actually something. It's not actually a practice. When you're meditating, you're simply no longer lost in thought. You're not identified with thoughts as they arise and therefore your attention is truly available to notice consciousness and its contents, right? And thoughts are among the contents of consciousness. So you're noticing, feeling and seeing and smelling and that the character of your experience more vividly and you're not being captured by this false point of view that you are the
但我对它的理解以及我认为我们应该对它的理解是，它其实不是某种东西。它其实不是一种练习。当你冥想时，你只是不再迷失于思维之中。随着思想的涌现，你不再认同它们，因此你的注意力真正可以用来觉察意识及其内容，对吧？而思想正是意识的内容之一。所以你在更生动地觉察感觉、视觉、听觉和嗅觉，你没有被那种“你是你思想的思考者”的错误视角所捕获。
thinker of your thoughts. Right. It's the absence of ego in a way, if you will. But for me, what was difficult was that maybe this is the condition of the world in which we live. Now, I don't know if it was easier to meditate 100 years ago or 200 years ago, but everything seems so busy. So I found it very, very hard when I first started to quiet my mind was much harder than
对。从某种意义上说，这是自我（小我）的消失，如果你愿意的话。但对流我而言，困难的是——也许这就是我们生活的世界的状态。现在，我不知道100年前或200年前冥想是否更容易，但一切似乎都太忙碌了。所以我刚开始时发现，要让我的心安静下来非常非常难，比我想象的要难得多。
I thought it would be. And I guess that's me. How do you think we feel when you're talking? That's where I wish you were in a two-year silent retreat. Sam, sorry, please continue. So Sam, a good life wouldn't be Sunday afternoon watching your favorite football game with a beer. Well, no, no, it could definitely be that.
我想那就是我。当你在说话时，你觉得我们的感受如何？那就是我希望你处于一个两年的禁语静修中。萨姆，抱歉，请继续。所以，萨姆，美好生活不会是周日下午一边喝着啤酒一边看你最喜欢的足球比赛吧？噢，不，不，绝对可以是那样。
Right? Okay. So, but this point of view, once you recognize that it's actually ultimately, it's not a matter of quieting the mind either. It's a matter of recognizing everything as it appears, including thoughts, right? So there's a metaphor in Tibetan Buddhism, which says that, you know, ultimately, thoughts are like thieves entering an empty house. There's nothing for them to steal, right?
对吧？好的。所以，但这个视角，一旦你认识到它实际上归根结底，也不是关于让心安静下来的问题。这是一个关于认出所有呈现之物（包括思想）的问题，对吧？因此，藏传佛教中有一个隐喻，说的是，归根结底，思想就像小偷进入空房子。里面没有什么东西可偷，对吧？
So you want to get to a point of view where everything is arising in its own place, right? There's just consciousness in its contents and every experience you could possibly have, whether it's on DMT or watching football, drinking beer, all of it has a single status. It doesn't preclude anything except the thing that does preclude and the reason why meditation is good for you, ultimately, right, apart from all the other ancillary benefits, like, you know, I mean, it may, in fact, be good for your health in other ways. But the truth is, I would recommend it, even if it were a little bad for you in all kinds of other ways, for this reason.
所以你想达到这样一种视角：一切都在其各自的位置上涌现，对吧？只有意识及其内容，你可能拥有的每一个体验，无论是通过DMT还是看足球、喝啤酒，所有这一切都具有单一的地位。它不排斥任何东西，除了那个确实会排斥的东西，以及为什么冥想对你有益的原因，归根结底，除了所有其他附带的好处，比如，你知道，我的意思是，它事实上可能在其他方面对你的健康有益。但事实是，即使它在其他各种方面对你有点害处，为了这个原因，我还是会推荐它。
It cancels the mechanism in your mind that leads you to suffer unnecessarily, right? When you look at the character of your psychological suffering, all of your worry and your anxiety and your regret and your shame and your embarrassment, all of it, right, is a matter of thinking without knowing that you're thinking. That's what the self is, really, I mean, the small self, the sense of being this embattled, you know, subject in the head. That's what it feels like to be lost in thought. I mean, you're like, you're having a conversation with yourself, paradoxically, that you're
它取消了你心智中导致你不必要地受苦的机制，对吧？当你审视你的心理痛苦的特征时，你所有的忧虑、焦虑、遗憾、羞耻和尴尬，所有这一切，对吧，都是在不知自己在思考的情况下进行思考的结果。这就是自我，真的，我是说，小我，那种觉得自已是头脑中一个腹背受敌的主体的感觉。这就是迷失于思维之中的感觉。我的意思是，你就像是在跟自已对话，荒谬的是，你
not able to inspect because you're busy, identified with each new thought that springs into consciousness. I mean, so just to take it right down to the tracks of this conversation, I'm talking, and each of you, if you're normal people, have a voice in your heads that is competing with just listening to what I'm saying, right? So I'm saying something and you might think, well, what the fuck does that mean, right? Well, that voice in the head, what the fuck does that mean? That for most people, that feels like a self, right? That feels like what they are, and that just springs into view.
无法审视这种对话，因为你正忙于认同涌入意识的每一个新思想。我的意思是，就拿这场对话的轨道来说，我在说话，而你们每个人，如果你们是正常人的话，你们的脑海中都有一个声音在与听我所说的话进行竞争，对吧？所以我说了一些话，你可能会想，这到底是什么意思，对吧？好吧，脑海中的那个声音——这到底是什么意思？对大多数人来说，这感觉像是一个自我，对吧？这感觉就像是他们是谁，而这只是突然浮现出来。
There's no perspective on it. There's no sense of there being space around it or that there's a condition in which it's appearing, and meditation is a practice of just dropping back and recognizing thoughts, images, and sounds in the mind, the linguistic sounds. Taking a step back and so like eliminating all those feelings of regret or doubt or shame, that is such a fascinating way. It can sound too abstract the way I put it, but if you think of what will prevent you from having the best day of your life today.
对它没有任何视角。没有任何感觉说它周围有空间，或者它出现的条件是什么，而冥想就是一种退后一步并认出脑海中的思想、图像和声音（语言声音）的练习。退后一步，从而消除所有那些遗憾、怀疑或羞耻的感觉，这真是一种迷人的方式。我所表达的方式听起来可能太抽象了，但如果你想想是什么阻止了你拥有今天生命中最美好的一天。
I mean, we all know what it's like to be deeply happy, at least if only for moments, right? To have a moment with your kids or your spouse or just yourself, just watching the sunset. We all know what it's like to just fully connect with the present moment in a way that doesn't leave us looking over our own shoulder, wondering whether this is going to get good or wondering what's going to happen a few moments from now or thinking about the past and how to get back. It's all about this moment right here, what is the thing that prevents that from happening on demand?
我的意思是，我们都知道深深的快乐是什么感觉，至少哪怕只是片刻，对吧？和你的孩子、配偶或独自一人共度时光，只是看着日落。我们都知道完全与当下连接是什么感觉，这种连接不会让我们回过头去审视自己，不会去想这是否会变得很好，不会去想几分钟后会发生什么，也不会去想过去以及如何回到过去。这一切都关乎此时此刻，是什么阻止了这种事情按需发生？
It is an inability to pay sufficient attention to the present moment. I remember distinctly as a kid having moments of discomfort and thinking, quite literally fantasizing about what it would be like to be a robot in that moment and to be completely cut off from emotion. I was almost envious of the inability to feel emotion or have those things or be, I wanted to be cut off from that in that way, the cut off from self and then I thought, well, that would be a great way to go through life and then you wouldn't be affected by anything. Of course, the sort of hole in that is that I wouldn't be able to enjoy a good experience
是对当下没有给予足够的注意力。我清晰地记得我还是个孩子的时候，有过感到不适的时刻，并字面意思上幻想在那一刻成为一个机器人会是什么样子，并完全与情感切断。我几乎嫉妒那种无法感受情感或拥有那些东西，或者成为的能力，我想以那种方式与此切断，与自我切断，然后我想，哦，那将是度过一生的一种绝妙方式，然后你就不会受到任何事物的影响了。当然，这其中存在的漏洞是，我将无法享受美好的体验
either because I wouldn't be able to enjoy any, I wouldn't be able to have any experience. This is a crucial point that mindfulness meditation, which is the type I recommend, isn't a matter of being cut off from even negative emotion. If you feel anger or regret or sadness, whatever it is, it's a matter of being willing to feel it totally. I mean, let yourself burn up with that emotion. The crucial difference is every time you notice you're getting lost in thought about why you have every reason to be angry or sad or how bad the future is going to be or what an asshole
了，因为我将无法享受任何体验，我将无法拥有任何体验。这是一个至关重要的点，正念冥想（我推荐的类型）并不是要与甚至负面的情感切断。如果你感到愤怒、遗憾或悲伤，无论是什么，它是关于愿意完全去感受它。我的意思是，让自己在那种情感中燃烧。至关重要的区别在于，每当你注意到自己开始沉迷于关于你为什么有充分理由愤怒或悲伤、未来会有多糟糕，或者那个人是个混蛋的思想中时。
that person was. I can't believe they said that on Twitter about me. Fuck them. That conversation, you have to break the spell of identification with those thoughts and be willing to just feel the emotion and you feel it a hundred percent. The default state is actually to avoid feeling it. We have resistance to these emotions. Part of what keeps you stuck in this automaticity of thinking about your anger, say, is an effort
我简直不敢相信他们在推特上对我说了那样的话。去他们的。那场对话，你必须打破对这些思想的认同魔咒，并愿意去完全感受这种情感，你百分之百地去感受它。默认状态实际上是避免去感受它。我们对这些情感有抵抗力。让你陷入关于你的愤怒的这种自动化思考中的原因之一，其实是一种
to solve the problem of, you don't want to feel this way anymore. You're angry and you're resistant to this feeling. You don't like this feeling and now you're thinking about all the stuff you should do to discharge your anger. I'm just going to tell her to fuck off. Watch. I'm going to type this. All of that is a way of not actually being willing to fully feel it.
想要解决这个问题的努力，即你不想再有这种感觉了。你很生气，你对这种感觉有抗拒。你不喜欢这种感觉，现在你正在考虑所有你应该做的事情来宣泄你的愤怒。我这就去告诉她滚蛋。看着吧。我要把这个打出来。所有这些都是一种实际上不愿意完全去感受它的方式。
If you do fully feel it and you break the connection to thought, nothing lasts. Anger lasts for 15 seconds. It's literally impossible to stay angry for a minute unless you get lost in thought again about the reason why you should be angry. On the other side of that realization is a freedom to just, you can decide, okay, well, how long do I want to stay angry about this? Is anger actually useful? I'm not saying anger is never useful, but it's rarely useful to maintain.
如果你真的完全去感受它并打破了与思想的连接，没有什么会持久。愤怒只持续15秒。除非你再次沉迷于你应该生气的理由的思想中，否则要在1分钟内保持愤怒在字面意义上是不可能的。在这种认识的另一端，是一种自由，你可以决定，好吧，那么我想为这事生多长时间的气？愤怒真的有用吗？我并不是说愤怒永远没用，但维持愤怒很少是有用的。
For me, it's useful as a signal, it's like a salient signal that something is really worth paying attention here. I'm in the presence of a total asshole who just did something to piss me off, and now how do I want to respond? Responding from that place of anger isn't usually the best course, but it gives you this. If you don't have any perspective on it, you will stay angry for as long as you'll stay angry for. I mean, you'll stay angry for a day, a week, and it'll have all the behavioral consequences
对我而言，它作为一个信号很有用，它就像一个显著的信号，表明这里真的有什么值得关注的事情。我遇到了一个彻底的混蛋，他刚刚做了什么事把我惹毛了，现在我想如何回应？从那种愤怒的状态中做出回应通常不是最好的做法，但它给了你这个。如果你对此没有任何视角，你就会想生多长时间的气就生多长时间的气。我的意思是，你会生一天、一周的气，它会带来所有的行为后果，
it has, and you have literally no degree of freedom there. I'm going to call you next time I want to fire off a reply email to my mom, because I think that you've been very... Waiting is a good algorithm, aren't you? She's going to be very helpful. She has been super annoying lately. I don't mind saying that on the podcast. Boy.
而你在其中字面意义上没有任何自由度。下次我想给妈妈回一封气冲冲的邮件时，我得打电话给你，因为我觉得你一直非常……等待是个好算法，对吧？她会非常乐于助人的。她最近超级烦人。我不介意在播客里这么说。天哪。
Well, Sammy, I can call you Sammy, right? Sure. I really have been such a fan for so, so long. I want to thank you for being here today, and I could listen to you talk all day long. I know. It's incredible. I really just find you so fascinating, and so thank you, and... Great to meet you guys.
好吧，萨米，我可以叫你萨米，对吧？当然。我真的是你的粉丝好久好久了。我要感谢你今天来到这里，我可以听你讲上一整天。我知道。这太不可思议了。我真的觉得你太迷人了，所以谢谢你，以及……很高兴认识你们。
I really appreciate it, Sam. Thank you so much. I hope when civilization reboots, we can meet in person. Yeah, that would be a blast. What a delight that would be. Yeah. Thanks for your time and your knowledge. Thanks, Sam.
我真的很感激，萨姆。非常感谢。我希望当文明重启时，我们可以亲自见面。对，那会非常有趣。那将是多么令人愉快的事啊。对。谢谢你的时间和你的知识。谢谢，萨姆。
Thank you, Sam. Nice to meet you guys. Appreciate it. Nice to meet you, Sam. See you, pal. Yeah. What a beautifully articulate guy he is. I mean, those are really abstract thoughts, and to be able to...
谢谢你，萨姆。很高兴认识你们。谢谢。很高兴认识你，萨姆。再见，老兄。对。他真是一个表达极其清晰的人。我的意思是，那些都是非常抽象的思想，能够……
I wanted to, all of his thoughts were so well thought out and articulated, as you said, and I wanted to, every time he finished it with a really long, great point, I wanted to go, that's what I always say. Have you guys ever read Letter to a Christian Nation? No. It's really fascinating. It's literally... You could read it like in a day.
我想，他的所有思想都是经过深思熟虑并且表达清晰的，正如你所说的那样，我想，每当他以一个真正漫长、精彩的观点结束时，我都想说，我一直都是这么说的。你们读过《致基督教国家的信》吗？没有。这真的很迷人。它简直是……你一天就能读完。
It's... I'm such a fast reader. I bet I could read it in a minute. You actually are a fast reader, aren't you, Will? I am, yeah. I do read a lot, but I will read it, and I know a bunch of people who are friends who we know who are big fans of his and talk about him all the time and love him, and it's just fascinating, right?
它是……我是一个读得很快的人。我打赌我一分钟就能读完。你确实是个读得快的人，对吧，威尔？我是，是的。我确实读了很多书，但我会读的，我知道我们认识的一群朋友，他们是他的超级大粉丝，整天都在谈论他并且非常喜欢他，这真的很迷人，对吧？
He's smart. You know what I meant to ask him? I meant to ask him if he knew, because I would think that Ricky, he and Ricky would share a lot of similar views. My new puppy? Not your new... But I haven't spoken to your puppy, so I don't know. Maybe...
他很聪明。你知道我本来想问他什么吗？我本来想问他是否认识，因为我觉得瑞奇，他和瑞奇会有很多相似的观点。我的新小狗？不是你的新……但我没和你的小狗说过话，所以我不知道。也许……
Okay, so his name's Ricky. Yeah. All right. Why would you say he and Dervais would be? Because Dervais is a... He's a... I was going to say a big atheist. He's not a big atheist, but he... but these are a lot of... he has a similar point of
好吧，所以它的名字叫瑞奇。Yeah。好吧。你为什么会说他和热尔韦（Dervais）会……因为热尔韦是一个……他是一个……我本来想说是个狂热的无神论者。他不是狂热的无神论者，但他……但这些有很多……他在很多事情上都有着相似的观点。
view on a lot of this. Did you ever see Dervais debate it with Colbert? No. No. It's fascinating. You can YouTube it. It's really cool. Wow.
你有没有看过热尔韦和科尔伯特的辩论？没有。没有。这太迷人了。你可以去YouTube上看。真的很酷。哇。
And funny. Dervais is hilarious on this subject. He's great. Yeah. I wonder if they know each other. That was very, very fulfilling. Thank you for the brain meal there, Sean. Yeah, for sure.
而且很有趣。热尔韦在这个话题上 hilarious（滑稽极了）。他太棒了。对。我想知道他们是否认识彼此。那真的非常非常充实。谢谢你带给我的精神大餐，肖恩。对，当然。
Sean, what a guest. What a guest. He's the best. All right. Until next time. Yeah. Until next time. What was my new sign-off?
肖恩，真是个嘉宾。真是个嘉宾。他是最棒的。好吧。直到下次。对。直到下次。我的新结束语是什么？
What was my new sign-off? Oh, I think it was... Bing. And bang. Pasta. Pasta. Jesus Christ. Oh, fuck.
我的新结束语是什么？哦，我想那是……Bing。还有bang。意面。意面。天哪。哦，操。
I hope COVID ends soon. It's eating your brain. Smart. Blast. Smart. Blast. Smart. Blast.
我希望新冠快点结束。它在吞噬你的大脑。聪明。精彩。聪明。精彩。聪明。精彩。
Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。